If you got 3 and 3 4ths that's great. I know I have three entire octagons. And
then I need to figure out this fraction. This is actually going to be 3 4ths.
Let's see why. I could have split my octagons into eighths. So I know I have
three whole octagons. And then I have 1 8th, 2 8ths, 3 8ths, 4 8ths, 5 8ths, 6
8ths of a hexagon. Remember, I know I can reduce 6 8ths, I know 2 goes into 6
and 8. So I can simplify it. And then I have 3 4ths. To find our improper
fraction, we just need to count up all the 8ths. If I counted up all the 8ths, I
would find out that I would have 30 over 8, or 30 8ths. Remember I can reduce
this fraction. So I get 15 over 4 or 15 4ths. But this doesn't quite make sense.
My picture has 8ths but my answers have 4ths. Well that means I could actually
have done this a little bit differently. I could have split up my octagons into
fourths. This would be 1 4th of the octagon. Notice when have fourths I can
easily see that I have 3 and 3 4ths. I have 3 whole hexagons, and then I have 3
fourths. 1 4th, 2 4ths, 3 4ths of this last hexagon. So 3 and 3 4ths.
Calculating of improper fraction is pretty easy too I can actually just use my
mixed number. Because this mixed number is in 4ths, I can figure out the
improper fraction in 4ths. I can multiply 4 times 3, which is 12. That makes
sense because I have three octagons, and to each of them has four pieces. Then I
have to add three more pieces. So I add 12 plus 3, and I get 15 over 4, 15 4ths.